and we have another recap here at the
chess club
st. Louis i'm joined by dog Eckhart
who's going to take us through one of
his games so we're gonna go ahead and
jump I'm having a pretty tough
tournament here but in this particular
possession I'm threatening Queen takes
pawn and I'm also threatening that if he
comes up and guards it I could play
Queen check he can't blame night here
because the Queen takes Knight check
king Jason night checks and if he loses
the King you know away some looks like
they're now I can play clean down here
and attack the night and I have some
threats so what he did was he played
clean here to keep my queen of these
squares allowing Queen Bey's age 6 he
plays before I have to play the night
here Queen takes pawn and we're both in
some time pressure here and a couple of
variations to look at one is to play
rook here at the idea of Brooke here and
black plays rook check King here rook or
queen f8 and now after i trained Queens
and say i take this pawn here he
complained night here rook takes pawn on
here and Olsen this is a potential mate
threat there so it's not that easy and
the other thing he can do is he can
bring his rook up to the square so after
he takes the pawn you can take there and
while we pawn up maybe not so easy to
win so what I thought that I could do
instead of all that was to bring this
back I didn't want to allow his rook to
get down there
so after he played Queen takes pawn I
brought my night back here and so now
the concept is if he guards his night
was either rooks now I have a cup and
rook over maining on a chain so what he
did was he sacrificed his Queen and this
probably should not work in this
position on Queen III and whites
probably a little bit better although
it's not easy i played this move and the
position should be a draw this so he
plays here takes takes Queen here night
here and unfortunately why can't take
the pawn here because after Queen takes
he has night check king here night chat
King here rorschach King here and I
check working the king and queen so what
I have to do instead is plate f3 in this
position to keep his night out of this
square and now he plays Knight check and
I'm sorry what I did I through Queen
check in first you have to play king
here he couldn't play King g7 kill the
Queen takes c3 in the night span and now
I played up three and he plays night
here and now if he brings his King back
here it's going to be very hard to stop
this bond so I set up basically a
perpetual check here for and now c 2 is
just a clear draw Queen shot king here
Queen check and he can't go up cuz it's
a shocking here and Queen door is made
um yeah amazingly enough he played night
to e3 here instead of c3 and we're on
the increment I agreed to a draw but
actually I can win with Queen check and
taking the night but yeah that's what
happens when you're having a not-so-good
term but it was an interesting game on
an interesting finish okay thank you
doing for sharing that game it's been a
pretty tough tournament for a lot of
people but thanks for showing us is very
interested in
complicated game we wish you the best of
luck and on the injury